today I'm starting with stunning new
leaked emails internal Fox News emails
that show that Executives knew when we
fact check Trump's election lies it's
bad for business if you are like the
last remaining person on Earth who
doubts whether Fox News is news or overt
profit-driven propaganda we can now put
that uncertainty to rest Fox News CEO
Suzanne Scott in a panic in the
aftermath of the 2020 election saying
we've got to stop these fact checks
telling the truth fact-checking Trump is
really bad for business there are any
number of write-ups about this CNN has
one article by Oliver Darcy and Marshall
Cohen from uh yesterday updated this
well actually from this morning
called Fox News CEO said correspondence
fact check of Trump's election lies was
quote bad for business new emails show
we're going to look at the emails in a
moment the article describes or
characterizes Suzanne Scott as sounding
the alarm about the financial Fallout
that they would suffer
if they keep fact checking Donald
Trump's lies
telling the truth isn't very profitable
when the monster you have created
over the last 20 30 years 30 years
doesn't actually want the truth they
want to be spoon-fed the lies that their
dear orange leader is perpetuating let's
take a look at a couple of these emails
in this first one this is Fox CEO
Suzanne Scott responding to a segment in
which Fox News is on air Talent Eric
Shawn fact checked a trump falsehood
and Suzanne Scott the CEO writes this
has to stop now this is bad business and
there clearly is a lack of understanding
what is happening in these shows the
audience is furious and we're just
feeding them material bad for business
she's talking about the fact checks the
fact checks are bad for business are we
news where we prioritize the truth or
are we propaganda where we prioritize
whatever lie is most profitable well we
know the answer here's another email
this one is is from Maria Bartiromo one
of the greatest Trump Brown nosers on
that network from November 7th where she
says they need War
they need War uh we have to go to a
full-on war they have used all systems
to defraud hammer or voting zinc the IB
side in the vote total Jared it's it's
crazy Jared says he doesn't want to hear
about any conspiracy theory
everyone us excluding me from meetings
we have to file federal suits in every
state the campaign is not doing s
they want to file lawsuits in a couple
places that's not going to solve the
problem this is Maria Bartiromo
seemingly a True Believer
falling for all of it she writes the
country needs to survive we have to keep
this President no one thinks anyway that
people voted for Biden he lost and we've
seen text messages from Maria and Steve
Bannon before that show they seem to be
true believers they don't seem to
actually just be uh telling what they
know to be lies Maria seems to genuinely
think that Trump won and it's Bonkers
another email
Uh Kevin McCarthy notes Kevin McCarthy
notes this is a pre-interview email
about Kevin McCarthy and
um this is from Maria Bartiromo I guess
to her team where she says you believe
Biden won one Fair there are a few
issues but I don't believe there is a
mass cheat oh wait a second
so she doesn't believe it in another one
I've not seen any proof so far of the
ballot fraud
well so maybe Maria Bartiromo believes
they need to do whatever whatever lie
they need to tell to keep Trump
but doesn't actually believe that there
was the fraud that Trump is alleging and
then Suzanne Scott on November 19th
2020.
saying I can't keep defending these
reporters who don't understand our
viewers this is like the epitome of she
gets what's going on
she says I'm getting major incoming on
her editorializing at the top of Dana's
Show and her dismissive tone and
indifference to the audience she means
not not just playing up The Lies We need
to manage this I saw she just did a hit
in Cavuto I hope she didn't double down
I can't keep defending these reporters
who don't understand our viewers and how
to handle Stories the audience feels
like we crapped on and we have damaged
their trust and belief in US think about
that
fact checking makes Their audience not
trust them she goes on to say we lost 25
000 subscriptions from Fox Nation we can
fix this but we cannot smirk at our
viewers any longer
she is saying our audience doesn't want
truth our audience wants us to keep
fueling the lies that Trump actually won
and this is what Fox News thinks of
Their audience they know our audience
wants lies they don't want fact checks
they don't want truth and it really
distills the entire operation of Fox
News into its immoral and dishonest
essence
stunning stunning revelations in these
emails now we go back to the question
that after the Fox News text message
leaks we asked after it was leaked that
Tucker was saying he hates Trump
passionately is this going to make Fox's
audience turn on them I don't think it
will and when we spoke to Matt Gertz
from Media Matters he also more or less
seemed to say the people who need to
hear about this stuff won't ever know
about it or if they come across it
they'll dismiss the reporting is fake
news they'll say oh David those email
screenshots are obviously doctored we
can't believe that that that those
aren't real no no no no no no Fox tells
the truth and the truth is Trump one now
Fox mostly knows that they're lying and
they know that the lies are the best
thing possible for business this is
where we are today it's tragic it's sad
I don't know how we deprogram these
people I've not found a way
but we at least now have it in black and
white and highlighted in yellow as you
saw in those emails Fox knows they're
lying and they know the lies are what's
most profitable for them